so we filmed most of this episode at the
beginning of this year
prior to when kovet uh had us
post-production
due to it being covered
so we weren't able to finish the episode
the way that we normally do
so you'll notice scenes like this filmed
in the highlander we're practicing
social distancing quesadilla are you
excited for quesadillas
i am excited for quesadillas i think
quesadillas are an all-time
great food whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
before you get into your disposition on
quesadilla's greatness
[Music]
today i'm worth it we're going to be
trying three quesadillas
at three drastically different price
points to find out which one is the most
worth it at its price
so andrew when you hear the word
quesadilla what happens in your brain
melty cheese in my mouth unrelenting
deliciousness
very poignant unrelenting deliciousness
i don't know what other foods fall in
that category where's our first stop
we're going to taco's 1986 joy and
victor are gonna show us their
quesadilla adobata spoiler alert it's on
a corn tortilla
which i've never had before
taco's 1986 what kind of taco shop are
you guys we're at tijuana based taqueria
i think we're representing carne asada
and adobala
from tijuana every taqueria down there
has those two tacos where does 1986 come
from that was the year we were born
i moved here about 10 years ago i was
missing that style of taco that style of
execution and that's pretty much what
sparked the whole thing my dream is to
see
five ten-year-olds eating our
quesadillas and being like this is
authentic this is a real quesadilla
you said a real quesadilla i think i
know what a quesadilla is but i probably
don't
have you had our quesadillas i have not
i'm about to change your life it all
starts in the handmade tortilla
we got the finest tortilla lady leticia
we'll start off with that
we completely stay away from drizzling
cheese on top we like to melt the cheese
first
on the griddle so it's nice and crispy
then we slap the tortilla on top
and flip it over you have a nice layer
of crispy cheese
the marinade in the northern region of
mexico we call it
adobada down south is known as al pastor
it's a rub that is used in the streets
of tijuana to kind of preserve meat that
we make with chilies
garlic we put strawberries and really
now yeah wow
my goal was to make the most delicious
one ever i think we accomplished i think
so
yeah people walk in here all the time
and they're like this is the uh alpa
store i'll get it off a storm
yes basically the same concept it's just
a different flavor
in our house a taco is a handmade
tortilla with your choice of protein
which can be
beef chicken mushroom or pork you want
cheese on your taco that's the case it's
not a taco anymore so we get that a lot
and they all come with onions cilantro
salsa guacamole and as you specify
otherwise
two quesadillas right here thank you so
much
please enjoy cheers
[Music]
oh my god whoa not what i expected at
all
i mean i guess i've been eating
quesadillas wrong my entire life i for
sure have i think my expectation was i'm
going to
bite and just taste the layer of oozing
cheese
right however in this quesadilla it's
oozing meat
pork is so delicious it's very rich and
meaty
with the cheese and everything else oh
and the tortilla is just it's the right
suppleness but togetherness right to
hold all this together
wow you ate yours very quickly i think
we should get more really
yeah yeah what is the perfect order here
taco and
quesadilla and then and then a secret
item that you don't know of yet
it's a flour quesadilla flour tortilla
with melted cheese a choice of meat my
preference is a carne asada i want
everything on it i use lunch guacamole
salsa and we top it up with a little bit
of bees
beans okay
okay beans baby cheers
mmm call it call it game over
first of all that meat is delicious
second of all this whole thing
is smacking i don't know how else to say
it this is just
all the slapping that's happened today
it actually tastes luxurious yeah with
the beans
should we eat more what we went from
quesadilla to the secret menu i say we
go
back to the beginning just have some
tacos keep it going
the heavens are now bathing my taco in
life
bury me here andrew nicky 1990
to 1986.
[Music]
so taco's 1986 was amazing i appreciate
his
uh level of care to those details even
to
plating it in such a unique way it feels
like a mic drop but it's like a mic
drop for every time you serve a dish
quesadilla fast i'm just yelling in my
bedroom right now in mexico city
it is not uncommon for cheese to be just
an optional ingredient for a quesadilla
what cheese optional how does that but
it's named after cheese what
you know it reminds me of it reminds me
of like those protein style burgers at
in and out
bun optional for those who don't know
can you explain that to people protein
style is when they give you
the burger patty in a lettuce wrap but
really a burger is kind of defined by
the bun
this is wild all right so next up
is an old friend of ours and yes i'll
call him a friend
uh we're gonna go see roy choi at cookie
taqueria to eat their kimchi quesadilla
so you might recall we did a takeout
episode where we visited the kogi truck
and in that episode adam actually ate
the kimchi
quesadilla so the very same quesadilla
but this time we're getting it from
the brick and mortar kogi location
i think i recognize this road kogi is a
food truck that started about a little
over a decade ago
you know a lot of people have dubbed it
korean and mexican but it's really la
it's not korea the country or mexico the
country it's
us like weird mutant kids that were born
from our parents who came from those
countries so this food is actually
from los angeles we have four different
types of tacos and then those all turn
into a burrito and then those all turn
into a quesadilla
so we're like a russian doll of tacos
the kimchi quesadilla was actually our
family meal we were just sitting there
you know waiting for people to order
food
and so i just started messing around
making stuff we take the kimchi we
caramelize the kimchi
almost like a jam we crisp the whole
quesadilla up kind of like a pizza and
we take that we cut that in four slices
shingle them down
and then we make a salsa roja very
similar to like a neapolitan pizza right
very simple ingredients very simple
construction but there's like an
alchemy and a moment in those 90 seconds
that you pull it out right so it seems
as though sometimes
people don't treat quesadillas with the
same love as they do with taco and i
feel like you gotta treat a quesadilla
as if it was a taco so you have to make
sure that every single bite
is a cohesive bite and you gotta treat
it right with a really good salsa
[Music]
first stop kimchi quesadilla smells
very when you get home and your mom's
cooking and you're just like trying to
guess what that is but then it's like
three different dishes at once
that yeah smell and it's like the kimchi
and the cheese
we have our slices shingled here would
you like the first shingle
i would you know one thing i noticed
about the interview with roy he kind of
talked about the food as if it was like
a living being
i understand why this is melting in my
hand
cheers steven
that was really great my first instinct
was andrew's gonna love this
i really love it it's interesting it
does have the consistency
of a neapolitan pizza you sense the
crispiness but it still has this like
moist drip to it there's something about
the creation of this quesadilla
that is a little intangible i don't know
what it is i think it's that
pizza moment magic that roy was talking
about when the quesadilla is
just crispy and melty enough it is also
the dichotomy of mom using big
end it's the dichotomy of the two
weird characters cheese and kimchi meat
like the unlikely duo in a buddy cop
film yeah
adam unfortunately couldn't join us for
this particular shoot so we're gonna
have
our stand-in sound operator take a bite
of this last quesadilla
mike come on in here
yeah that was amazing i think we've
pointed this out before in the show but
i just love how
there are cities that have given birth
to combinations
of foods that you would not expect to
see
really surprising and delicious so for
our final
stop in our quesadilla journey we're
seeing chef ocho
at all flavor no grease for the triple
threat
very excited
all flavor no grease got started from a
dream
actually i was tired of selling wheat
i'm not going to front
and i'm like lord i need something else
better to do with my life a small voice
actually came to me was like do what you
learned how to do in school the only
thing i learned how to do in school was
sell candy and make friends and i was a
heavyset guy i didn't have all the nice
clothes but i knew how to be a bubbly
person so i opened up a candy
house in the front of my mom's home
about three months later a friend of
mine was like you should start selling
tacos that was said one friday that
tuesday i tried it it was a success i
sold out just started going crazy after
that
man i would describe my quesadillas as
an americanized mexican dish because
i'll never take away from the culture
you feel me i've been brought up and
raised around hispanics basically my
whole life and the quesadilla was not
only a vision that i had but
wasn't nobody taking off with the
quesadilla one day i'm cooking up my
little tacos and stuff my friends still
came through to support but yet still
talk to those smack you know still shoot
the fat jokes they were irritating me so
much
i was like you guys need to shut up that
was the exact
cut look everything that i seen in my
dreams so then i thought outside the box
let's start using steak
we'll keep the chicken but now let's get
a little bit more fancy let's use some
shrimp too
and we have a cold marinade that we put
on there that actually turns the shrimp
a nice bright orange color and i'm like
okay
this would be the triple threat with all
three proteins we try to use all the
regular fats and the oils from the meat
so we don't have to add any and that's
how we stick to the all flavor no grease
concept
the triple threat is for a first time
customer because that's gonna be flavors
coming from every different angle i'm
happy that i do cut it at eight to ten
pieces that way
you don't have to pick up a big
hamburger form you could just hope
just by one little long rectangular
piece people ask all the time like why
does it taste so good cause i put love
in there
it's a little salt and pepper but you
know a lot of love in it i say all the
charisma
and the whole style of all flavor no
grease came from
me being me and when i was able to
finally come out of that shell like that
i was embraced by so much love that i
didn't even know i
had from people
all right you guys hungry i'm starved
you better because we got
the triple threat first observation the
shrimp is
looks like it's out it's from out of
this world it's fluorescent red
i honestly i thought it was a tomato at
first i thought it was a pepper
that's a little shrimp taste cheers
it looks like a firework of sauce
like the different zigs and zags going
in opposite directions
cheers
wow shrimp
and the beef and the chicken it makes
for like
a lot of different flavors that happen
in one bite you know that chart like
neutral what is it like neutral good
like the character creation card
for for dungeons where are you putting
this i think i would say
chaotic is for sure i think it's good
yeah
i agree with you i absolutely think it's
good it's a very
heroic flavor you know because it's
chopped up in these slices
it's kind of more like eating a great
plate of nachos
every bite is that last cheesiest
corner place where everything is loaded
in there you know
the whole quesadilla is that it has the
same
tantalizing effect as like french fries
like when you have 10 of something
you're like oh man i can't wait to chow
down on box of fries
the flavor lives up to the moniker
triple threat
so it's the end of our quesadilla
journey so andrew
which quesadilla was the most worth it
to you guys given price point i think
i'm gonna go
with all flavor no grease the triple
threat
is that unrelenting deliciousness that
i'm
after i can't reiterate how amazing of
an episode this was
to do in los angeles i got i guess i
gotta go kogi takaria i mean i can't
i can't believe i'm saying that adam
what's your worth at winter tacos in
1986.
okay well that does it for the
quesadilla episode thank you for joining
us on this
delightful trek in two quesadillas next
week we have a very fun episode
that is something that we've never done
before so for our season finale
we're actually doing two high-end
restaurants
head-to-head it's going to be wild
[Music]
[Music]